yawn is whether Seon is in California
hyeyeon welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
how you doing Dave better than I deserve
what's up
so my economic dilemma is I have what I
have been told is a outstanding
unresolved debt with a revolving credit
card company and I can name names if you
want or not if you don't this found who
is it
Capital One okay and so you you owe them
money and you haven't paid them properly
how much money well here well here
here's a deal um I did a debt
consolidation with them a low-interest
card you know for the life of the
arrangement deal with you know this will
never go up and yada yada turn your high
interest to low interest and I did all
that wouldn't good state and then
gradually over time they started jacking
up the interest rates in nineteen point
seven four percent from two point nine
nine percent and humanely no one lied
yeah shocking so though and anyway so I
called them every I called them on their
junk every time and I said look what are
you doing here we're moving in the wrong
direction and I gave them several
opportunities along the way to
renegotiate the contract with me and say
look let's move it to something else
let's keep the interest rate at a
reasonable level no sir no sir this is a
district Lee a business arrangement
decision has nothing personal you know
we still love you but you know bend over
and so anyway I just got to the point
where I said look you know what I'm
gonna make a personal business decision
and the decision is I'm not make I'm not
paying you anymore
I'm done and and so $10,000 outstanding
balance ballooned into 14,000 and change
with late fees and fines and all this
stuff and then they finally throws it
and then I and then I again I gave him a
last best chance of negotiation and I
said look you know what can we do to
resolve this thing and they said well
you can pay us you can make monthly
payments of $1,300 a month until the
full balance is paid off or you can give
us a lump sum payment of $10,000 and I
wasn't able to do either of those and I
said look that doesn't work for me is
there anything else and they said
absolutely not so how long ago
how long ago was that approximately two
years ago okay and so where do we stand
today so it's in collections with the
collections agency and it's been
outstanding for like thirty nine months
yeah and I being told that people take
39 months of our resolve that this
afternoon for it to be removed for my
credit report and get my credit rating
up again yeah so I just want to resolve
the thing but but I am at an impasse
with them and they they're not they're
not open minded they're just giving me
one hard option and that's it and I'm
just trying to forgiving you it's the
1,300 month till it's pasty or 10,000
yeah that's it the collection agency
didn't they haven't been paid in 39
months and that's their best offer yes
okay yes all right let me tell me what
what what what's your advice thirty nine
month old credit card debt will usually
settle for around 20 cents on the dollar
okay perfect and that's of the existing
balance current including all the crap
so four thousand dollars we'll probably
settle at cash on the Barrelhead but
you're probably gonna have to argue with
them and as you have already discovered
credit card collectors or stupid people
yes because if they could get a good job
they'd be working somewhere else
correct and they also lie as you've
already discovered from Capital One yeah
okay so you have to treat this like
you're a snake handler and not get a bit
okay and you just you just pound them
and pound them and pound them and pound
them and it's like I'm not gonna listen
to you be abusive you're getting right
talk to a dial tone you idiot okay now
listen listen fool if you guys want
money it's real simple
there's two things you're gonna do
you're gonna give me the settlement in
writing and you're not having electronic
access to my checking account because
they are crooks they will clean out your
checking account you cannot give them
access to it okay so you send a wire you
send a certified mail yeah a prepaid
debit card with nothing else on the card
except the exact amount you settle for
and you negotiate this to about four
thousand dollars in writing no access to
your checking account
got it yes and can I also stipulate with
them that once the dispute is resolved
that all
records of it be removed for my credit
rating immediately and not very
difficult to pull off okay okay cause
they are not supposed to do that
they're supposed to under the agreement
with the credit bureau report what
occurred and what occurred was you
haven't paid your bill in 39 months okay
and now sometimes you can talk them into
it but it's it's on their part it's
unethical okay and let me ask you
something when I was one following one
final question hmm
if I go forward and I need to establish
some sort of business arrangement with a
utility company or landlord or something
is that mark enough to knock the wind
out of my sails is that enough to like
throw my train off the tracks no not at
all it's it so it's a worse mark today
because it's a bad debt unpaid
then it becomes a bad debt settled that
means you've made it made good on it
right and so it does it does positively
affect you and it will remain all credit
remains on your credit bureau report
good or bad for seven years okay except
for a chapter 7 bankruptcy which stays
on 10 years but this one thing is not
going to keep you from living your life
it's it's the only thing ever in the
entirety of my and you learned your
lessons dealing with credit yes yes good
okay yep all right if that's all it cost
you then you're gonna be okay you'll be
all right it's not a it's a horrible
lesson to have to learn horrible way to
have to learn it but if it's thorough
and you never go back it's probably
worth it settle it in writing no
electronic access to your checking
account it's not in writing it didn't
happen an email is fine keep a hard copy
of the email a hard copy of the payment
receipt in a file for the rest of your
life because these people are
incompetent and they're crooked you can
tell a credit card collector is lying if
their mouth is moving there's scum
thanks for calling a guy hit me on
social media that they I don't like you
like it when you say credit card
clickers you're scum I'm a credit card
clicker I'm like dude you either get a
better job then then you wouldn't be
scum
because the industry is they break
federal law there's a federal law called
the Federal Fair Debt Collection
Practices Act the way that you're
supposed to interact with the consumer
when they owe you money and they break
that law on a daily basis and they lie
we work with them all time it's the scum
of the world man so best ways never have
a credit card and never have credit card
debt and then you don't deal with all
this stuff some of you think I'm being
melodramatic but you haven't talked to
American Express and Discover in Capital
One like we have